similarly the theological tenants of
Christianity developed over the
centuries too such as the idea of the
Divine as somehow consisting of three
principles the father Son and Holy
Spirit from a certain perspective one
can argue that such ideas and readings
of scripture were very much in
conversation with the philosophical
traditions that were popular at that
time such as platonism and others which
often had a three-part scheme of higher
realities too just look at platinus and
the neoplatonist their one New Soul
hypothesis for example but that isn't to
say that because these terms and general
ideas were present that the Nan form of
the Trinity as we know it existed in
earlier period